S
HAVE TO SWEAR TO AS WELL.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING US NOW IS
SENATOR TOM COTTON, WHO WAS PART
OF THIS -- I CALL IT A FARCE
BECAUSE ALL OF THESE HAVE BECOME
POLITICIZED OVER THE YEARS.
SENATOR COTTON, THIS POINT OF
THIS ONE CASE WHICH I DECIDED TO
FOCUS ON, IT'S AN AREA OF LAW,
AS YOU KNOW, FOR MANY YEARS,
IMMIGRATION LAW, THAT I THINK IS
BEEN ABSOLUTELY RASTERIZED BY
ACTIVISTS AND SADLY JUDGES.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US ABOUT HER
JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY, WHICH SHE
DECIDED SHE WASN'T GOING TO
ADDRESS TODAY?
>> LAURA, THE CASE TELLS US THAT
JUDGE JACKSON IS A FAR LEFT
ACTIVIST.
SHE ALWAYS HAS BEEN, JUST
BECAUSE SHE PUT ON A BLACK ROBE
TEN YEARS AGO, SHE DIDN'T
CHANGE.
AS YOU OUTLINE, SHE TOOK IT
IMMIGRATION LAW THAT REMOVED ALL
JURISDICTION FROM THE FEDERAL
COURTS, REMOVAL OF -- THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ACTED ON THAT
LONG SHE STILL REVIEWED IT AND
SHE STILL ENJOYED THE REGULATION
NATIONWIDE.
HER COURT OF APPEALS, ONE OF THE
MORE LIBERAL COURT OF APPEALS
SAID THAT IT WAS A BLATANT
DISREGARD IN PLAIN LANGUAGE.
GOES TO SHOW THAT FAR LEFT
ACTIVISTS WILL TAKE THE STEPS
THEY WANT TO ACHIEVE THE
RESULTS.
IF THERE WAS ANOTHER CASE THAT I
HIGHLIGHTED, LAURA.
THE FENTANYL KINGPIN, TO USE HIS
OWN WORDS, SHE SENTENCED HIM
BECAUSE OF MANDATORY MINIMUMS --
SHARED HIS FRUSTRATIONS.
CAME BACK LATER FOR A BOGUS
COVID EARLY RELEASE -- DENIED
THAT SHE HAD TO, BUT THEN SHE
JUST TOOK IT ON HER OWN
INITIATIVE FROM A SENTENCE WHICH
SHE NEVER WANTED TO IMPOSE IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT'S THE KIND OF --
>> Laura: SENATOR WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A PART OF THAT --
>> THE LAST FEW DAYS.
>> Laura: SENATOR, JUST SO
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T WATCH THE
HEARING TODAY, I WANT THEM TO
SEE WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SO
THEY UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS.
WATCH.
>> BEFORE YOU GRANTED THIS
FENTANYL KINGPIN'S MOTION TO
REDUCE HIS SENTENCE, DID YOU
CONTACT ANY OF THE VICTIMS?
>> SENATOR, MR. YOUNG WAS NOT
RELEASED.
HIS SENTENCE WAS REDUCED AND I
DID NOT CONTACT THE VICTIMS IN
THIS CASE BECAUSE THERE WERE NO
VICTIMS.
HE COMMITTED A CRIME, A DRUG
CRIME, THERE WERE NO
IDENTIFIABLE VICTIMS IN HIS
CASE.
>> DRUG CRIME IS NOT A
VICTIMLESS CRIME.
>> Laura: I MEAN, WE HAD
51,000 OVERDOSES I BELIEVE JUST
IN THE PAST YEAR, MOST OF THEM
INVOLVED SOME LEVEL OF FENTANYL
OVERDOSE, ISN'T THAT RIGHT,
SENATOR, HOW DO WE CALL THAT A
VICTIMLESS CRIME IS BEYOND ME.
>> IN THE LAST FULL YEAR FOR
WHICH WE HAVE DATA, IT'S 100,000
OVERDOSES, LAURA, SO THAT'S NOT
JUST 100,000 VICTIMS, BUT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF LOVED
ONES, OF PARENTS AND HUSBANDS
AND WIVES, BROTHERS AND SISTERS,
CHILDREN, FRIENDS, WHO ARE BEING
KILLED BY THE POISON THAT IS
COMING IN ACROSS OUR
UNCONTROLLED SOUTHERN BORDER.
JUDGE JACKSON, LIKE SO MANY FAR
LEFT ACTIVISTS, THINKS THAT
MANDATORY MINIMUMS FOR DRUG
CRIMES ARE TOO HARSH, JUST LIKE
SHE A PARENT I THINK THAT
MANDATORY MINIMUMS FOR CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY ARE HARSH.
SHE CONSISTENTLY SENTENCES ON
THE LOWEST END OF THE SENTENCING
GUIDELINES OR EVEN DEVIATES
DOWNWARD FROM SENTENCING
GUIDELINES.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST FEW DAYS EXAMINING HER
RECORD SHE IS A FAR LEFT
ACTIVIST WHO ALWAYS -- ALMOST
ALWAYS -- FINDS A WAY WITH THE
CRIMINALS, NOT THE VICTIMS.
>> Laura: SENATOR, I JUST
STILL CAN'T BELIEVE SOUL
UNREVIEWABLE DISCRETION.
THAT'S WHAT THE STATUTE SAYS IN
THE IMMIGRATION CASE AND SHE
REFUSED -- JUST REFUSED TO APPLY
IT AND SAID NO, I CAN REVIEW
THAT AND TOTALLY INVALIDATED IT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IT'S ASTONISHING, LAURA, AND
AS YOU SAID, HER COURT OF
APPEALS IN WASHINGTON, D.C., IS
NOT EXACTLY A BASTIAN OF
RIGHT-WING THOUGHT.
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST LIBERAL
COURTS IN AMERICA THEY HAVE BEEN
REPEATEDLY REVERSED BY THE
SUPREME COURT FOR ENGAGING IN
SIMILARLY EGREGIOUS DECISIONS,
BUT EVEN THEY SAID THAT THIS WAS
BEYOND THE PALE, IT WAS ONE OF
THE WORST EXAMPLES THEY HAD EVER
SEEN OF DISREGARDING THE PLAIN
LANGUAGE OF THE STATUTE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN
MISINTERPRET SO UNREVIEWA